across poland's at coal heartlands this
is a familiar site every day of the year
and has been for decades power stations
working non-stop to keep the country
running
this is the biggest and most carbon
polluting power plant in the whole of
europe it is the bellator power station
and it accounts for around a fifth about
20 percent of poland's total energy
requirement and it's fueled by this
colossal open pit mine we can see in
front of us here
and it employs
nearly 10 000 people
[Music]
but everyone across the industry is
deeply worried about the future as the
transition to renewables means coal
should be phased out entirely by 2049 at
the latest
so the question is what happens to the
miners
i understand changes taking place in the
mining industry are necessary but those
changes have to put people first there
must be a just and fair transition
securing their existence
for the government the green transition
is a huge challenge it admitted to al
jazeera it's unlikely to hit the 2050
carbon neutral target agreed by the eu
it might be a few years
beyond that we haven't set that goal
specifically in our in our legislation
today we are currently working on uh
on a strategy until 2050 but that hasn't
been finalized
at the moment
that stance certainly does not make the
forthcoming u.n climate negotiations in
glasgow any easier with their focus on
the phasing out of coal and bad news too
because from a health perspective the
green transition cannot come soon enough
across poland toxic coal smoke billows
from millions of chimney tops
and this at a time when the world health
organization says that air pollution is
more dangerous than previously thought
killing an estimated 7 million people a
year
in poland itself air pollution causes 45
000 premature deaths each year while the
country has some of the most polluted
air in europe and 36 of europe's 50 most
polluted cities are in the country
but in the once badly polluted city of
krakow science is hitching a ride into
the evening sky
every time this sightseeing balloon goes
up on-board sensors send air pollution
measurements down
in 2019 city authorities banned the
burning of fossil fuels within city
limits and the effects have been
immediate we see a great change in the
city
the quality of the air is
improving
the krakow experience demonstrates the
possibilities ahead for poland
phase out coal you slash emissions and
clean up the air at the same time
but getting there is the challenge
nick clark al jazeera silesia poland